c'est vraiment une c'est très excitant
comme opération convolant surnom en
octobre rené doyon vous êtes directeur
de l'institut de recherche sur les
exoplanètes inversée de montréal merci
d'être avec nous se noyant est ce
qu'avec ce monstre qu'on va déployer
dans l'espace à l'automne prochain
est ce que c'est ce monstre qui va nous
donner la réponse que l'on cherche
depuis toujours j'allais dire est ce
qu'il ya de la vie sur d'autres planètes
écoutez si on n'a pas la réponse on va
devoir faire des pas importants pour
avoir la réponse a dit violent devient
sous les lignes et là on reconnaît
maintenant plus de calme et l'exoplanète
et une poignée qui sont vraiment des
mondes qui sont pas totalement habité
est la clé pour savoir si c'est mon de
laon de la vie c'est de détecter leurs
mots ce faire on le fait déjà avec le
télescope spatial robots mais il n'y a
pas la puissance suffisante pour le
faire correctement et web pourra le
faire et d'ailleurs
l'instrument canadiens que nous avons
conçu et est conçu spécialement pour
faire justement ça non seulement
détecter l'atmosphère de ces planètes là
mais aussi d'en déterminer la
composition chimique
sk de l'eau est-ce que du co2 du méthane
qui sont les éléments importants pour
que la vie y apparaissent
il sera commencions par le début il sera
en orbite ou le james webb
alors comme on le voit ici sera lancée à
1.5 million de kilomètres au delà de
l'ata donc ça c'est très différent tout
risque à bord qui lui est seulement 500
km en orbite autour de la terre est la
raison pour laquelle on la voit si loin
ce qu'on veut le mettre constamment dans
l'ombre du soleil
monsieur albert le biais d'une île à
laon le télescope web detec la lumière
infrarouge de la lumière que au delà du
fret à 1.5 million de kilomètres il va
tourner autour de la terre néanmoins
exactement fanni va suivre la terre dans
son orbite autour du soleil donc il sera
constamment dans l'ombre du soleil grâce
à son écran solaire qui est la taille
d'un terrain de tennis et donc et comme
ça on pourra et derrière il ya le
panneau solaire et toutes les toute
l'ailé les antennes de communication
priorité donnée sur tarn et garonne
trois antennes sauteur constamment qui
pourront prendre les données de james
webb
bon d'accord et il va pointer parce que
dans le dans la voie lactée inc
si quoi entre 100 et 400 milliards de
soleils
alors il va pointer vers où est-ce qu'on
a déjà déterminé quelle étoile nous
intéressait quelle planète nous
intéressons autour de ces étoiles
absolument d'ailleurs on l'a vu le temps
d'observation maintenant été alloués
pour la première année du télescope et
le web offert une panoplie d'observation
d'abord dans notre propre galaxie on a
parlé de l'exoplanète encore ce sont des
étoiles devant tout près du sol l on
parle de quelques dizaines d'années
lumière et aux confins de l'univers on
va observer aussi les toutes premières
galaxies de se sont allumées on pense
quelques centaines de millions d'années
après le début de l'hiver le big bang
bang et on ne peut pas encore vraiment
sondés cette région là d'ailleurs web
qui conçut vraiment pour ça au tout
début il y avait un temps là de devoir
les premières lumières le plus grand feu
d'artifice cosmique qui ait jamais eu
lieu dans mon livre je vais aller au big
bang après mais restons dans notre
galaxie pour l'instant dans notre
galaxie je le disais il ya un nombre
incalculable des toiles de soleil et
donc de planètes qui tournent autour de
ces soleils on a déjà la liste est ce
que sur cette liste là vous vous dites à
telles exoplanètes
il devrait peut-être avoir de la vie
tels on on a déjà de liste de
sélectionnés
absolument on ne mentionnera partage au
début le fameux système trappistes un
système planétaire vraiment unique
laissé la vedette pour pour les
exoplanètes l'on compare deux systèmes
planétaires qui est une étoile à peine
plus grosse que jupiter autour de
laquelle auj
cette planète qui tourne autour on sait
que c'est bien être long à peu près la
taille de la terre dont trois qui sont
dans la zone habitable donc la zone ni
trop loin ni trop proche de l'étoile
pour qu'on puisse espérer trouver de
l'eau liquide alors comme le 6 mai dit
olivia on ne sait pas encore si c'est
pas la honte une atmosphère est la seule
façon de savoir c'est avec les
instruments à bord à bord du web et donc
olivier a eu du temps d'observation mais
aussi dans le cadre de notre
contribution canadienne
on a toujours du temps guerre
garantie 400 dollars dont la moitié
seront dédiés justement pour étudier le
système donné vers l'or alors on va on
va chercher s'il ya de la vie sur les
exoplanètes et vous l'avez dit on va
aussi regarder très loin donc dans le
passé de l'univers et l'on va regarder
les autres galaxies et puis plus loin
plus loin
est-ce qu'on va se rendre aussi loin
qu'on n'était jamais allée quoi tout à
fait donc l'instrument que le test coop
est permis d'aller aussi loin là c'est
le test cap rabadan dans l'espace mais
malheureusement arabe aux limites parce
qu'entre autres il observe surtout dans
le domaine visible donc et comme le dit
monsieur albert les galaxies très
lointaines et mettre surtout leurs
lumières dans le domaine infrarouge donc
on ne peut pas y échapper
et c'est pas un hasard s'il est capable
le disque web été conçus pouvaient dans
l'effroi rouge
on doit absolument observer ces galaxies
là d'un domaine infrarouge donc et on
parle de galaxies se sont formées l'a
peut-être 400 300 millions d'années
après le big bang et jusqu'où on peut
aller
mais c'est à peu près la limite donc
avant ça il sa pente d'autres
instruments qui sont différents de ceux
de celui de web là mais ouais ben pour
ce qui est de d'étudier les études des
buts de nivet remparts en fait les la
formation des toutes premières galaxies
donc mais la forme de l'univers est ce
qu'on va en savoir davantage à ce qu'on
va arriver à cette réponse est ce qu'on
va comprendre davantage l'univers et au
delà plus ou moins donc il ya d'autres
missions spatiales qui sont davantage
des dires cette question-là spécifique
la web et en intro télescope d'usagé
général qui va adresser on parle des
galaxies lointaines on parle exoplanètes
mais c'est beaucoup plus que ça que web
va faire donc c'est un programme de
deuil
il ya plus de 4000 chercheurs dans le
monde sont impliqués dans la dent dans
les programmes d'observation qui ont
lieu dans la première année très bien
monsieur doyon va reparler à l'automne
c'est tout ça est lancé
il est lancée le 31 octobre prochain on
va reparler parce que l'élément canadien
et montréal est important des supports
quelques secondes tu te fais en fait
c'est l'instrument canadien qui a été
conçu en grande partie à diverses
montréal donc en face hideuse ses deux
caméras dans une donc une caméra qui est
absolument critique pour les âges
télescope la caméra de guidage il faut
comprendre que chaque fois que de webo
pointe est un corps céleste c'est pas
parfait et donc il ya des vibrations et
donc le télescope vive d'autant que les
images sont embrouillées alors il ya à
bord un petit miroir qu'on peut basculer
et la caméra canadienne pour détecter un
mouvement du télescope et ce mouvement
là et il est tellement précis qui lie
les clients de mesurer l'épaisseur d'un
cheveu à un kilomètre donc c'est la
pression et la caméra canadien du porc
on va se reparler monsieur doyon merci
beaucoup nous avons pas ça